le pire est à venir leurs interviews
expliqué à ma fille non annoncé votre
petite fille qui parle par ma bouche
comme dans l'exercice dis maman
il est où papa et un appel n'a pas voulu
de temps dis maman c'est qu'ils
jean-edouard je te montre avec a7 qui
comprend 10 moment tu n'aimes bien stv
oui j'aime beaucoup et la fille qu'il
aime bien jusque-là ça là on verra plus
tard et a redit son trait à un g2 non
dit maman comment on fait les bébés
respecter un petit peu plus tard quand
on a grandi
donc tu m'expliqueras loi dis maman
pourquoi le monsieur qui vient des fois
la maison il tombera sur la bouche
ah parce que parce qu'il aime beaucoup
pourquoi on ne voit plus tout le temps
la télé parce que je préfère m'occuper
top-10 maman le monsieur qui embrasse
tout le temps sur la bouche
il a fait la même chose à la baby sitter
l'a fait revenir la masia ces mines dit
là bas non dit maman on va rester
toujours ensemble maintenant voilà merci
je fais c'est une chanson spécialement
pour moi j'aime toucher
je t'aime par l'eau